欢迎回来
这节课的第一部分中
我们已经看了在 Haskell 中定义函数的简单例子以及和其他语言的区别
Haskell 中的条件是表达式而非语句
但 Haskell 程序员更常用的是守卫等式 而非条件表达式
另一项内容是如何使用模式匹配定义函数
特别是使用模式匹配 来定义列表上的函数
下面要讲的是如何直接定义函数 因为 Haskell 是一门函数式语言
需要有一种简洁的方式定义函数 那就是 lambda 表达式
你或许知道其他语言中的 lambda 表达式
如果你是 Java 程序员的话 Java 8 中引入了 lambda 表达式
如果你是 C# 程序员的话 你一定知道 lambda 表达式
如果你是 Hack 或 PHP 程序员的话
里面都有 lambda 表达式 在 JavaScript 中同样也有
lambda 表达式无处不在 随便举出什么语言 C++ D Swift 每门现代编程语言都有
在第一节课中讲到过 它是20世纪30年代阿隆佐·丘奇（Alonzo Church ）发明的
大多数语言中的 lambda 表达式都很相似
在 Haskell 中 它是这样的
lambda x 箭头 接下来是函数体
实际的代码中不写 lambda 字母（λ）
而写斜线（slash）比如 \x
不写箭头符号（→）
而写 -> 但在课件中为了美观
写的是 lambda 字母和真正的箭头符号
但当你在写代码时 需要用斜线代替 lambda
用讲过的那种方式写箭头 那么它到底是什么
这是一个函数 接收 x 并把它加到自身上
这一函数没有名字 因此是一个函数类型的表达式
这就是 lambda 表达式的本质
也就是表示函数的表达式
在数学中 按丘奇的设计
读 lambda 代数文献时会看到 写成 lambda 字母 但打字时写成斜线
不写数学中的箭头（↦） 而写这样的箭头（→）
但就其他方面而言 Haskell 是最接近 lambda 代数的语言
因为它是基于纯函数的（pure functions）
而其他语言中的 lambda 表达式称为闭包（clojure）更准确一些
之后可以看到原因 它们可以“封闭”外部变量
但是那些 lambda 表达式可以有副作用
但我们之前说过 其实不要紧
我们强调的是 函数式编程是使用表达式进行编程
lambda 表达式有什么用呢
它可以让你更好地表达函数柯里化（currying）的意图
第一个例子中 不写 add x y = x+y
这是一个柯里化的定义
这个函数接收一个参数 x
返回一个函数 接收参数 y
最终返回 x 加 y
实际上这样表达 意图就更清晰了
add 是一个函数
接收参数 x 返回一个接收参数 y 的函数
最终将它们加起来
上面实际上是下面形式的一种语法糖（syntactic sugar）
当写 Haskell 时 我总是写下面这种形式
尽管更长一点
也就是说要打更多的字
但我认为这种形式可读性更好
在课程当中 我们会交替使用两种形式
但当你看我的 Haskell 代码时 我倾向于显式地写出 lambda 来更好地表达函数柯里化
当希望明确表示返回值是一个函数时 也可以用到 lambda 表达式
某种意义上说 和柯里化类似 这里定义常数函数
这是一个函数 给定 a 就会返回一个函数
返回的函数无论接收什么参数 b 都会返回 a 类型 定义如下 const x
返回一个函数 无论接收什么参数 都忽略
并且返回 x 因此常数函数
可以用一个 lambda 表达式十分简洁地定义
这种形式就不那么清晰 const x _ = x
它没有强调返回的是一个函数
下面在类型上也用括号进行强调 而在上面就没有
我会用下面这种方式写 我会在类型上加上括号 并且将函数写成 lambda 表达式
下面是另一个 lambda 表达式的用处 避免起名
起名时编程中最难的事情之一
需要起有意义的名字 因为语言常常强迫你起名 而有时并不想起名 只想直接传值
比如如果将一个函数 map 到一个列表上
我没有理由给这个函数起名为 f
f 本身又传达了什么意义呢
相反 我可以只传入一个 lambda 表达式来 map 整个列表
上面这种不是地道的 Haskell 下面这种才是
需要起名的唯一情况 就是要多次使用
或者是让事情更清楚 但这种情况也因人而异
下面介绍 Haskell 的另一个特点 叫做分部（sections）
通过分部 可以将一个中缀的二元运算符 比如 加运算符 当作函数使用
通过在周围加上括号 就可以当作函数使用 比如 1+2 结果是 3
括号+ 接着 1 2 同样是 3 这是一个有用的技巧
因为可以同样使用分部写 (1+) 以及 (+2)
通过在加号周围加上括号 可以部分应用加法
可以写 (1+) 它是个函数 需要接收第二个参数并加 1
这个 (+2) 的分部是需要接收一个值 在上面加上 2
因此最终都是 1+2 结果是 3
一般而言 如果 ⊕ 是一个二元运算符 可以用  (⊕) 将其当作一个正常函数使用
可以使用左右分部来部分应用这个函数
这点会在 Haskell 中经常见到
比如这里 如果想写一个增加1的函数
可以直接写 (1+) 分部有什么用呢
下面是几个例子 要写一个将参数值折半的函数
只需要写 (/2) 就可以了
而不用写 \x -> x / 2 因此分部可以让写代码时不用起名
这就是练习中要表达的
起名很难 希望避免它
分部可以帮你做到
下面是练习的预览 可以在课程网站上找到习题
练习中 需要使用这节课中教授的结构来定义函数
我保证 这是最后一个特定于 Haskell 的练习了
但既然一直在讲 Haskell 和其他语言如何不同
我想通过做练习熟悉 Haskell 语法 对听课很有用
各位 Hacking 愉快
下周再见 拜拜